e.t exclusive with dog the bounty hunter
dwayne chapman
it's been just over a year since his
wife of 13 years beth passed away from
cancer
now he's introducing us to his fiancee
giving him
a second chance at love brother kevin
the last interview we did
i said kevin i talked to a lady before i
got here
she had lost her husband the wife just
lost the husband months ago
out of nowhere died so wow i'm thinking
i need to meet with her
you know tomorrow before this right
well kevin meet francie so nice to meet
you
clearly these two were meant to be
francie's husband bob passed away from
cancer just six months before beth
now just over a year later she's proudly
wearing that beautiful engagement ring
and they even have matching vine tattoos
we're both still grieving we're never
going to leave
bob and beth behind and we were
dealt a really hard hand the engagement
came as a shock to many and dog told me
multiple times he would never marry
again
she would say big daddy you better not
let another girl take my place
i said i won't she's like if you do
i will haunt you she haunted me for a
bit
and they'll never be another mrs dog but
by god they'll be a final mrs chapman
my grandson calls him grandpa dog
already
i see your show's coming do you want to
tell me now will you go back to a
network because i
i feel this happens well but let me tell
you hollywood's shut down
the reality shows are gone for a minute
okay i mean it's tough brother
but october 6 you can catch dog playing
himself
in the new faith-based film hunter's
creed the one
the only dog the bounty hunter
in the movie he helps another man cope
with the death of his wife
lover kisser hugger you become a movie
star
thank you did you say that everything i
wanted to be i've become
i've been famous in a legend of my own
mind since i was a young man
really and his relationship with francie
is making him feel
even younger by the day he's trying to
quit smoking he's doing a really good
job
i eat plant-based and so he's juicing
with me
and his blood pressure is normal it's
never been more
normal so i think he's lost 30 pounds
since we've been together
she's going to keep you alive forever
man yes sir you just bought a few extra
years on egg
amen that's right
you